le calme avant le coup de feu les portes
sont ouvertes mais les visiteurs ne
peuvent pas encore rentrer la cité de la
gastronomie attend sagement son
inauguration dans les rues de dijon
l'ouverture suscite de l'impatience
finalement nous avons vu les plans
certaines maquettes mais bon c'est vrai
que le réel est toujours plus plus
fantastique j'ai vu des bus athées
l'hôpital et puis la réalisation
oui j'ai l'impression que ça va
redynamiser le quartier ça c'est
vraiment intéressant la cité compte
s'appuyer sur les trois millions de
touristes qui viennent à dijon chaque
année en plus elle l'espère deux cent
mille visiteurs payants ce commerçant
s'est installé à quelques mètres du site
en juin 2021 ils pensent pouvoir séduire
de nouveaux clients
on va changer surtout sur la partie
épicerie avoir un peu plus de produits
qui sont destinés à une clientèle plus
touristiques qu'une antenne locale de
façon à ce que quand les gens sont à la
cité l'ex sony puisse profiter de
certains produits qu'on aura en rayon
des produits bourguignons auquel on
pourra mettre aux références en rayon
l'inauguration conclu trois ans de
chantier au total 200 millions d'euros
ont été investis dans le projet à
l'extérieur les ouvriers peaufine
désormais est les derniers détails ah
oui c'est la course un tuner touche de
partout pour que ce soit va nickel pour
l'inauguration à l'intérieur on se
prépare également
françois aulas commissaire des
expositions s'activent pour que les
quatre salles thématiques soit prête le
jour j en vo nous surprenait en pleine
finalisation de l'exposition voyait le
chantier donc là on est dans la partie
pâtisserie on est en train vraiment de
finir finir pour que dans quelques jours
sa soir l'émerveillement total et pour
cette ouverture les organisateurs ont
mis les petits plats dans les grands
avec un programme qu'ils espèrent
alléchant un pack de 21 euros sera
disponible pour venir visiter les lieux
et goûter quelques plats puis pour les
personnes qui veulent simplement faire
un petit tour une inscription en ligne
sera possible allez gratuite au total
c'est mille personnes qui sont attendues
pour le premier week-end de la cité de
la gastronomie